Bob: Hello! My name is Bob, and I'm a contractor for Fabletech. Make itfable.com
Bob: today. My
Bob: hardware is my dell laptop. It's a Dell latitude. It's about a year and a half hold we've got windows. 11 is my operating system, and it is
Bob: updated.
Bob: And then my, my screen readers. Jaws. It's jaws 2023. And it is updated to the most current
Bob: version and updates and I've been using jaws for over 30 years now, so consider myself pretty proficient at it.
Bob:  And then my browser's edge.
Bob: And so then, moving away from that.
Bob: the purpose of this request that I've been given is to assess how I feel about the fable upskill page
Bob: and a couple just going through a couple of the superficial levels of the classes
Bob: to see if this would be suitable for me, coming as a
Bob: potential customer. I've been given access to a demo
Bob: and a demo account, and so now I'm I've logged in with that demo account. and then just those around the page, and and see how things
Bob: go and
Bob: give you my impressions. So. to start with. I always go control home to make sure the focus is at the top left corner at the very furthest.
Bob: the very earliest place on the page versus vertical bar fable, upscale, vertical bar fable, upskill.
Bob: Okay, very clear and straightforward. Thank you. I appreciate that.
Bob: Typically, since I'm just kind of navigating around first thing since I'm up in that top left corner is I'll use my arrow keys and just arrow down and around just to see what's up in navigation for quick moment. Same page link skepta main content. Thank you for that. That's always helpful right at the beginning.
Bob: I don't always want to get stuck in navigation. and having that skip to main content is extremely helpful. Main region.
link, graphic fable, dashboard.
Bob: Okay, so this is this is one thing that I thought was a bit
Bob: redundant, and I'll tell you why in just a moment. So we've got a graphic. That's that's a link to the dashboard. But navigation region get in the navigation region. The very first link is Mr. Dwightum's link dashboard.
Bob: So it's linked dashboard. So it's kind of redundant. I don't know if you just want to have
Bob: for me, it'd be fine just having the graphics there at the very beginning. And in the navigation. The global navigation area is where you'd have the link.
Bob: Just my opinion link courses. So we got the courses link. Okay? So I'm just gonna keep going through
navigation region. End fable, 1,692,307,485 fable button collapsed.
Bob: Not sure what that is. that says Button collapsed. It's got a whole bunch of numbers and things.
Bob: and feeble at the beginning. If this was my user Id, II suppose I would have appreciated a label saying, user id
Bob: right before that.
Bob:  But again, I'm I'm not sure why it would be collapsed. And I'm just curious. I'm going to click on to see what. Maybe there's some options for me with classes. Space expanded main region, banner region fable, 1,692,307,485 fable button expanded to activate, press, enter
link preferences. link log out. getting level, one courses.
Bob: Oh, okay.
Bob: link log out link preferences. Interesting? I'm not gonna go diving into it because it's not the the scope of the project today. But I wouldn't mind knowing what preferences we're supposed to be.
Bob: what preferences would be
Bob: listed under here table, 1,692 million space collapsed. So I'm collapsing that and that I'm just the other thing I wanna do right now is, see what kind of headings we've got here.
Bob: So 10 which helps me navigate through a page in the site a little bit quicker. Narrator, heading list, dialogue headings, list, view courses, Colon, 1, one of 9, to move to items, use the arrow keys. I've got 9 headings. My active courses. Colon 3, 2 of 9.
My accessibility journey. Beta-colon, 3, 3 of 9.
My my accessibility journey. Beta. Colon. 3, 3 of 9. Bookmarks. Colon. 3, 4 of 9. My available courses. Colon. 2, 5 of 9. Introduction to accessibility. Colon 3, 6 of 9.
Accessible mobile apps, Colon 3, 7 of 9,
Bob: accessible. Web development. Colon 3, 8 of 9. Accessible user experience, Colon 3, 9 of 9.
Bob: The heading is very straightforward and seem to be in a nice order. Thank you. That's helpful. I'm gonna go
Bob: back to the beginning of this
home courses, Colon 1 one of 9.
Bob: Okay. so just to see that it works getting level, one courses
getting level. 3. My active courses heading level, one courses.
Bob: But kind of thought that that would be a h 2
Bob:  only because we've we've got pretty much the H one being the landing point on the page. It's just my opinion. I'm really not assessing this for
Bob: accessibility and
Bob: all that I'm supposed to be looking at in terms of someone coming into it. But
Bob: it's just my opinion on, you know, cleaning up some things getting level. 3. My active courses
link introduction to accessibility.
Bob: So my active courses wonder what my inactive courses would be
Bob: my active courses. Does that mean that these are the courses that I have access to level 3 my active courses?
Bob: Since I'm I'm in a demo account.
Bob: I'm just thinking, going forward. What would this mean to me? My active courses? Yes, those that I've paid for
link introduction to accessibility.
Bob: Okay. Well, let's let's see what this one is. I'm gonna hit. Enter loading page
introduction to accessibility, vertical bar fable, upscale, vertical bar fable, upscale introduction to accessibility, vertical bar, fable, upscale, vertical bar, fable, upscale loading complete pages, 4 regions, 10 headings and 16 links. There are 9 small glance, highlight list of 2 items.
link courses, grader link, introduction to accessibility.
Bob: introduction to accessibility, vertical bar, fable, upscale, vertical bar, fable, upscale. I hit control home for a reason. Same page, link, skip to main content. We've got skip to main content. Main region.
link, graphic fable, dashboard
Bob: navigation region. Okay. that's true. Williams.
link, dashboard link courses.
Bob: listend navigation region end fable, 1,692 million breadcrum navigation region. Oh, good. There's some breadcrumbs in case I need to get out of a rabbit hole getting level, 2 breadcrumb
Bob: list of 2 items linked courses, grader link introduction to accessibility list, end, breadcrumb navigation region end. That's always helpful. I appreciate the breadcrumbs level, one introduction to accessibility overall progress, Colon, 0% complete.
Bob: So really, all I'm doing right now is using my arrow key for a reason, because I'm just trying to discover
Bob: without missing anything, heading level. 2 course details.
Learn about accessibility by understanding disability and assistive technology. This course has 6 short modules that take 5 1 0B min to complete
Bob: 5 1 0B min. Maybe it would be more more natural. 5 to 10B min if there's a way to control that  modules.
Bob: Learn them getting level. 2 course details. Okay, so this is a relatively quick course. I like the fact that there's
Bob: information summary, of course. Purpose. Learn about accessibility by understanding disability and assistive technology, and the course has 6 short modules that take 5 dash, 1 0B min to complete
Bob: and how long it should take to complete modules. 6. Link continue learning.
Bob: Okay?
Bob:  I suppose the first link the first time I come through would be start learning.
Maybe I'm just being picky.
Bob: Instead of continued learning, I would expect that if I was returning to them to this particular course. to continue where I left off.
Bob: But right away, I guess I'd say I would have expected to say, start learning, heading level, 2 modules, heading level, 3 about digital accessibility.
Available table with 2 columns and 7 rows.
Activity status link about the introductory course. Link, meet your instructor.
Link, meet your kodas instructors. Link. What is digital accessibility?
Bob: The table link me to link meet your instruct link about the introduct status.
Bob: It doesn't sound like anything is being read from status.
Bob: Now I know this is dummy data, and I'm I'm we're walking through a demo. Ii suppose I would have expected maybe not at this point, but
Bob: something in the status field activity. Since we've got the activities link about the introductory course. Link, meet your instructor. I assume all these are activities.
Bob: And it doesn't just move right over to a status next to each activity link, meet your co-dashing instructors, link what is digital accessibility
link types of assistive technology
linked digital accessibility. Quiz.
Bob: table end
Bob: linked digital accident. Blink, link, meet your instructor. I'm curious as to meet your instructor. Just curious to see if it's even an active link. Enter loading page
Bob: about digital accessibility, vertical bar, fable, upscale, vertical bar, fable, upskill about digital accessibility, vertical bar, fable, upscale, vertical bar fable up link, introduction to accessibility link about digital accessibility list, end, breadcrumb navigation, heading, cutting level to course, outline, same page, link, skip to activity. So I'm gonna go back back, going back, loading page, loading. Complete introduction to accessibility. Vertical bar, fable, upskill, vertical bar fable, upskill. Link, meet your instructor instructor.
Bob: I like to meet the your instructor. That's that's neat, link. Meet your kodas instructors and
Bob: other instructors. Very good. Let's see down here a little bit
heading level. 3 about disability, unavailable table with 2 columns and 8 rows
Bob: about disability. I know this is dummy content, not just wondering if this is dummy content, or what? What is going to be here? Level 3 about disability, unavailable
table with activity, your experiences with accessibility unavailable
Bob: is this area where I would type in
Bob: incidents that I can recall of events where I'm aware of disability challenges or events that have happened. We have a 15 unavailable
thinking about disability, unavailable cultural model of disability, unavailable. talking about disability unavailable.
Bob: So I guess my my question would be, is, what what would be the intent of this this block?
Bob:  is it to capture my own impressions?
Bob: Or is this stuff that I've learned from the materials disability quiz unavailable table end? It's the 2 3 screen readers
available table with 2 columns and 40's activity
status
Bob: link screen readers. Okay, alright, I got you. I got you. It's part of the training. All right. I'm gonna go back to our settings and back, going back, loading page, loading complete settings. A more left parental plus f right paren button menu.
Bob: Alright. So I don't know if I'm actually on the home page or not. I'm just gonna do a little
Bob: control f 6 control f 6 courses vertical bar. Fable, upskill vertical bar, fable, upskill dash, left bracket guest, right racket, microsoftage left parengue gestrian courses vertical bar fable upskiller okay, so what I did is control. F. 6, which takes you back to the very beginning of a website, no matter what doesn't matter where you are on the page.
Bob: So I want to get to another one. So I am going to see how these links look. We do insert F. 7
links, list, dialog links, list, view, skip to main content. One stable dashboard, 2 of 10 dashboard, 3 of 10 courses, 4 of 10.
Bob: There's another thing, too, is the link before the navigation. 2 links in a row that say, dashboard in the list of links. Insert F. 7. It's not really clear as to what's the difference between 2? Is there a more overarching dashboard called Fable Dashboard.
Bob: and another one may be unique to me. So we've got an organizational level that would be a little confusing. Horses, 4 of 10.
Introduction to accessibility. View badges, 6 or 10,
Bob: all of you badges.
Bob: Hmm! What are badges? Let's see. Enter loading page.
Bob: vertical bar fable, upscale, vertical Bar Fable, Upskill, Vertical Bar Fable, Upscale Vertical Bar. Fabel Upskill loading complete Pageness, 4 regions, 6 headings and 7 links. There are 4 smart glance highlights on this page getting level. 2 breadcrumb list of 2 items, link courses, greater link, accessibility. That whole
Bob: bit of verbiage at the beginning seemed a little redundant and not really
Bob: coordinated through badges. I guess I would have expected it to say. View my badges or view badges, and maybe is this, since I'm the the training manager. Is this a summary of
Bob: all the badges of
Bob: all the people that are signed up for courses, or that I've signed up for courses? Or that should be taking courses. So I could look at a an overview of how many badges and what badges in a table form
Bob: that the other employees have completed
Bob: breadcrumb navigation region ends. Okay? So I want to get to it. Let's see if there's table on here. There are no tables on this page. Okay, no tables.
Bob: Accessibility champions made a heading level, one.
Bob: Disability champions. Okay? So a little confusing terminology changed from badges to champions, disability champions, care about building products that are usable for everyone. You were part of making that happen. As you learn new skills in practice
them, you will progress through levels. Remember, every member of a team contributes to building accessible products. heading level 2 level, one accessibility champions at this level have a baseline of knowledge about digital accessibility and assistive technology. They have a strong desire to learn
more about how they can take action to build accessible products. requirement complete that link introduction to accessibility
course, status not started, inactive fable accessibility, champion badge and gray with a minimalist drawing of a lock icon above a bridge. Graphic
Bob: gotta admit. This is a bit confusing to me.
Bob:  I'm not sure what the intent is.
Obviously
Bob: it does say, you know, it talks about completion, etc. But I go back to my previous comment, which is. would this be an overarching table
Bob: showing the progress of the entire organization? Or is this specific to me? And again, it did change from view badges the link on the previous page on the home page
Bob: to champions. So II am. I am a bit confused about that level 2 level 2,
level 2 accessibility champions at this level have a baseline of knowledge about digital accessibility and assistive technology. They have a strong desire.
Bob: Okay, so I get it. This is about the explanation of different levels. And
Bob: I guess each
Bob: badge is earned at the completion of a course.
Bob: So at this level. Those people who have completed 2 courses hitting level 2 level, 2,
level 2 accessibility champions at this level have a baseline of knowledge about digital accessibility and assistive technology. They have a strong desire to learn more about how they can take action to build accessible products.
Bob: And I would suggest not letting these blocks of text be choppy. If if it's a paragraph of text, let it read through, is a whole paragraph of text.
complete 4 modules from any of the other available courses
Bob: complete 4 modules, not complete. 4 classes
Bob: status.
Bob: It would seem that you'd have to complete a class to get a badge. My opinion.
Bob: I guess I would prefer that
Bob: it's not really helpful if I'm the hiring manager, the Hr manager, and I'm having to figure out what modules go with what? I guess I would have expected to see this in the chart
Bob: with progress for each person.
Bob:  Amen!
Bob: Like I said, in the list of badges
Bob: what they've completed in terms of the classes.
Bob: and if it's incomplete, then it's incomplete
Bob: to me. It wouldn't matter how many modules have been completed unless there's a purpose for listing that not started. Inactive fable accessibility chutting level, 2 new levels coming soon.
Bob: having level 2 new levels coming soon. Main region end, main region end. So I'm at the end of that, all right. Well, that was interesting.
Bob: Not what I was expecting, but it was interesting.
Bob: I'm gonna go back a page to the green page again, going back loading page. See how things are moving around. Another another heading. Let's see what happens here. Well, I wanted to go back through that list of links instead of 7 Links List dialog links, list view introduction to accessible mobile apps. 8 of 10.
Introduction to accessibility set accessible. Mobile apps, 8. Accessible web development, 9 of 10. Accessible user experience, 10 or 10 accessible accessible mobile apps, 8 of 10. Introduction to accessibility, 7 of 10 viewpages, 6 or 10.
Bob: Introduction to accessibility, accessible mobile apps. 8 of 10. Curious that would be is that a class
accessible, mobile apps, vertical bar, fable, upscale, vertical bar fable, upskill. Accessible, mobile apps, vertical bar fable ups breadcrumb.
Bob: Okay. Accessible mobile apps, heading level one I hit H. For heading to go
Bob: beyond all of this navigation. I know I could have done skip to main content, but it's easier for one jaws keystroke to hit an H and just skip beyond all that
Bob: overall progress. Colon, 0% complete. Okay, so this sounds like a class level, one accessible mobile apps
Bob: could be stated as a class or a module for a class progress, Colon, 0%, complete heading level. 2 course details. It does say, of course, here.
Bob: like, I suppose, in the links.
Bob: or somehow to identify it, it would be. It would be listed as a class, because in the links it doesn't say that it's a class. It's just a bit of information. Learn how to create mobile apps that work well for all users, including people who use assistive technology. You can choose to take the Ios or android
Bob: Us or Android stream. This course has 7 modules that take 1 0 1 5B min to complete.
Bob: It seems like the intent would be to take both because of the popularity of both. One or the other kind of pigeonholes my people into
Bob: one path. You know, I want to be able to develop apps that I can put on Google's play and on in the app store
modules one.
Bob: So this is a class of level. 2 modules getting level, 3. Mobile app accessibility. Unavailable
table with 2 columns in activity about the mobile course unavailable.
Meet your codach instructors unavailable about the mobile course, unavailable activity.
Bob: Okay, so people with 2 columns and 40's
Bob: fill with 2 columns of 4 rows activity, I got activity about the mobile course unavailable. There's no header label for what I would assume would be status, which would be the second column
activity.
Bob: Okay? So.
Bob: wrapping the top table with 2 columns and 40's column, one row, one activity. Okay, so and all I did was hit T again, or hit T to take me to see if there's a different table. I'm gonna hit. H. From wrapping to top breadcrum heading level, 2 accessible mobile apps heading level. One
course, details, heading, level 2.
Bob: Okay? So I just keep hitting the HTML, how to create mobile apps that work well for all users, including stream. This course has 7 modules that take modules.
Bob: Okay. Modules. Heading level, 2.
Getting level, 3. Mobile app accessibility. Unavailable table with 2 columns and 40's heading level. 3. Mobile app accessibility. Unavailable heading level. 2 modules.
Bob: Okay, I hit it.
Bob: Interesting. Well, let's see what else we've got here. Going back, loading page loading complete courses. Vertical bar, fable, upscale, vertical bar, fable, upscale, heading, level 3, link accessible mobile apps. Okay, I'm gonna do control F, 6 again.
Bob: Just to get me back control and fourth.
Bob: learn how to create mobile apps that work well for all users. Interesting
control. F, 6,
getting level, 3, link accessible mobile apps.
Bob: I guess I'm I'm at the beginning of the page. Learn how to create mobile apps. That work with accessible web development heading level 3 link
Bob: accessible web development websites that work well for all users, including people who use assistive technology. This course has 6 modules that take 1, 5, 2 0B min.
Bob: Yeah, that whole dash 2 0. It's more natural, if it could be that timeframe could be such as 5 to 20B min to complete
Bob: and let it read it all. There's one, if possible. understand? That might be a field. But to the user I just want to be able to read that block of text, not did be broken up overall progress. Colon, 0%, complete
heading level 3 link accessible user experience. Learn how to build user experiences that work well for all users, including people who use assistive technology. This course has 6 modules that take 1, 5, 2 0
minutes to complete
Bob: same thing, overall progress, colon 0% complete
main region end.
Bob: Okay, product locks round button.
Bob: I said, main region end and then product block
walk throughout
Bob: spelling error
product walks round button.
Bob: That could just be the way Jaws is pronouncing it. But
Bob: let's see, I'm curious. Rao, a LKT,
h
Bob: ROUG. So it's not spelling. It's more of a grammar thing. Maybe I can suggest just from being picky
Bob: put a dash in there so that
Bob: jaws or the screen, reader, I don't know what form
Bob: might read that as separate words and pronounce it correctly. Walk through.
Bob: I think someone with a with any cognitive issues related to something like this might have a problem with it, being called walk through and not understand what that is. Product block through button
product walks round button
Bob: product, walks around button. Okay? So
Bob: it said, I was at the end of main content and had this information. After that. Kind of strange.
Bob: Alright. The only other thing that I can think of, that I'd want to do and is, I want to see. It's good virtual HTML. Features, dialog list, one list view and curs list one of 22 to move to items. Use the arrow. Let's see what else is in this layout list. 2 of 22
block quotes, list 3 of 22 buttons. List, 4 of 22,
Bob: and take a look at the buttons. Enter to activate, press, enter, select a button dialog list. One list view product walks round button 2 or 2 to move to items. Use the Arrow key fable, 1,692,307,485 fable. Button, one and 2.
Bob: Okay, so this is where, if I was looking at a list of buttons, neither of these would make really much sense to someone who wasn't familiar with it. Product walks around button 2 or 2. So there are just 2 buttons on the page. Escape press enter, escaping out of that.
Bob: This has been very interesting courses. Vertical bar, fable, upscale, vertical bar fable, upscale.
Bob: Ii guess I'm gonna wrap up now and say that
Bob: I see the benefit
Bob: in this. I think it. It's a helpful demo. I didn't really run across any accessibility. Snags.
Bob: There are some opportunities, I believe, to clean up
Bob:  just for content, clarity.
Bob: and
Bob: maybe navigation a little bit easier, such as taking a look at the heading structure on the front page on the landing page.
Bob: But it it all made common sense. I mean, it was all yeah. It all made sense.
Bob:  the links for the fable. Excuse me.
Bob: but not.
Bob: and I can't think of the name of it. Dashboard! There we go, fable, dashboard versus get into the navigation, and then and dashboard it. It implies that there are 2 different dashboards. I would work on that
Bob: view badges. and
Bob: see if there's more of a Hr. Way to title that as a link. and then you get to the page with
Bob: the the championing part, and you could you could view the badges as a table at that point, for each person
Bob: shows their status and
Bob:  and then there there were no stati statuses
and any of those tables. I understand that there's a lot of dummy text
Bob: II just. And there was also a table that didn't have a column header
Bob:  other than that I found it easy to navigate
Bob: very straightforward.
Bob:  I appreciate the opportunity. And normally, I'd say on behalf of fable tech. But this is fable tech
Bob:  But thank you. Thank you for taking my input seriously
Bob: and giving me the opportunity to review this. Have a nice day.
Bob: Please stop.